l'invité que je devais accueillir
maintenant et écrivain et cinéaste
quantité des bouquins il en vend des
millions d'exemplaires et quand il fait
des films il ya des millions de
téléspectateurs
c'est alexandre jardin
y avait plein art
bonsoir soit tout le monde connaît
alexandre jardin quand même julie bout
connaissez tous le monde le ferait avec
son tueur la nuit bouquin à son premier
bouquin justement c'était bille en tête
en 1986 l'histoire d'un jeune homme de
16 ans qui séduit une amie milliardaire
de son père et on a cru d'ailleurs c'est
tellement bien tout le monde a cru que
c'était votre père qui l'avait écrit
pascal jardin on a cru que c'était
françoise verny votre éditrice qu'il
avait écrit et finalement c'était vous
ce que je n'ai écrit d'autres depuis
puis votre père malheureusement n'est
plus là et françoise verny n'est plus en
état donc
trois cent mille exemplaires et prix du
premier roman pour un premier roman donc
bravo déjà très beau début alors je les
fais pas tous mais je cite les plus
connus a pris le zèbre en
1988 vous avez été le plus jeune lauréat
du prix femina un million d'exemplaires
traduits dans six pays et un film fait
par jean poiret enfants 1990 neuf cent
mille exemplaires
c'est ce pays-là ce coup ci c'est plus
six et seize le zubial en 97 qui
consacre à votre père justement qui
votre véritable entrée en littérature
c'est l'accueil critique du faut être un
petit peu le museau sur vos bouquins sur
le zubial je crois qui a pas eu de
discussion tout le monde a reconnu un
vrai talent d'auteur voilà pour les
livres on passe au film alors il lui
faut enfants en 93 donc avec sophie
marceau et vincent perez 1 million de
spectateurs
il ya paris il ya un truc qui rassure
quand même c'est quand 96 il ya un échec
ça fait plaisir d'un seul coup ça vous
ramène dans la normalité on voit que
c'est un être humain comme les autres
que vous trompez donc ça s'appelait oui
en 96 et c'est un échec et aujourd'hui
bas
voilà alors a commencé avec le livre
autobiographie d'amour voilà donc chez
gallimard autobiographie d'un amour
là c'est toujours tous les héros
s'appelle alexandra vous le dira c'est
quoi ces de la mégalomanie de l'ironie
c'est quoi non c'est pendant très
longtemps je n'ai pas trop aimé ma vie
et je me ferai le luxe avec un stylo de
mener une vie acceptable et d'écrire sur
des personnages que je trouvais beaucoup
mieux que moi c'est un peu fini bon donc
mais bon quand même ça plaît toujours
alexandre les héros parce que dans votre
film on va parler après il s'appelle
encore avec ces bons moments d'ailleurs
le dernier à l'exemple que je crains
c'est la fin d alexandre d'accord alors
dans ce dans ce bouquin autobiographique
d'un amour donc
sélection du moment du livre qui
découvre que sa femme se sent un peu
seul dans son mariage il disparaît il
disparaît la laisse quand même avec les
avec les gosses c'est surtout un type
qui découvre la vérité de sa femme un
joueur qui tombe un jour sur le cahier
intime de sa femme et qui découvre avec
qui vit et la dernière fois que ça vous
est arrivé à vous ben oui comment moi
j'ai divorcé une fois déjà
bien en gros ils découvrent une
catastrophe il découvre que c'est trop
tard et ils disent pas et deux ans après
son frère jumeau qui revient et son
frère jumeau il est très inspirée de
l'oeuvre d'un psychiatre américain qui
me passionne qui s'appelle milton
erickson qu'est ce qui dit eriksson
c'est quoi son message c'est quelqu'un
qui a une approche complètement
stratégique c'est à dire que lorsqu'il
s'adresse à quelqu'un tout ce qu'il fait
va être destiné à le manipuler pour
arriver à le faire changer à son insu et
quand je dis à son insu c'est quelqu'un
qui ne qui ne parlent jamais directement
par exemple si s'il veut faire un
compliment une femme il ne va pas dire
vous êtes jolie il va dire je vous
trouve désirable et lorsque je vous
trouve lorsque je trouve une femme
désirable ça me donne soif il va se
mettre à boire un verre d'eau comme ça
linda c'est pour toi
voilà
il y une vieille copine tout mais c'est
vrai jeu mais c'est vrai vous avez été
parmi les les sectateurs les
thuriféraires de l'est derrière vraiment
défendre linda en france avant se
rendant bien avant tout le monde bon
avant ruquier avantage 9 pour la
première fois que j'ai vu en concert on
était de ces têtes dans une toute petite
salle au sentier des halles il y avait
plus de monde sur la scène que leurs
intérêts c'est vrai club des amis de
lynda lemay ce soir
ixon et donc il va dire par exemple à
une femme
lorsque je trouve une femme désirable ça
me donne soif il va boire un verre d'eau
ouais si le lendemain il se pointe
devant la fille qui lui dit rien mais
qu'il la regarde en coin qui boit un
verre d'eau est bien évidemment
comprendre c'est à dire que c'est tout
un cible ce sont c'est toute une
stratégie indirecte et à dire lui il est
mal à le mettre là quand je m'emmerde
pendant une émission
qui fait que dans la suite de l'émission
chaque fois qu'il ya un plan sur le hip
hop voilà il aura une action
ericksonienne
génial et gels anti c'est l'anti frêche
quand on dit c'est lanthier freud ce qui
le passionne ce n'est pas pourquoi les
gens vont mal mais comment ils vont
pouvoir changer ouais et ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de mettre en place des
stratégies pour faire changer et c'est
ce que fait le héros de ce livre bien
pour ça c'est autobiographie d'aller
m'en souvenais vendu qu'on est assez
énorme vous êtes toujours dans les
250 milles je me soumets manga sans
250000 tu peux jouer
bien et maintenant on passe
pas ce film parce que jardin quand il
vient c'est pas pour rien
si la compil c'est l'acronyme jardin
accompli alors on passe donc le prof
d'après un roman à vous qui s'appelle le
petit sauvage qui sortent donc ça sort
le 12 avril avec jean hugues anglade
yvan attal hélène de fougerolles
alors ces deux grands propre comme on
aurait aimé en avoir à l'école chacun
incarne une dit si je me trompe à chacun
incarne une partie de nous-mêmes une
facette de nous mêmes c'est à dire les
envies et les peurs sûr que tous ses
envies et tous des peurs et y en a qui
essaye de faire en sorte que qu'une
génération entière des élèves d'un lycée
sortent avec un avec un bac qui signifie
qu'ils vont avoir une véritable capacité
à rester vivants c'est à dire une
capacité à n'être qu'un changement est
et c'est vrai que quand on était gamins
on sait bien qu'entre 6 ans et 6 ans et
demi et 7 ans ont changé et lorsqu'on
commence à entrer dans le monde adulte
c'est le grand coup de frein et tout à
coup qu'est-ce que vous êtes devenu en
trois semaines depuis trois semaines
c'est pas sûr que vous allez continuer à
évoluer ouais alors que trois semaines
alors que alors que alors que vos gamins
ça sort et on aurait tous buts à leurs
trois semaines alors qu alors que nos
gamins en trois semaines ils ont
continué et bien c'est exactement ce qu
anglade essayent de faire avec ses
élèves il décède le fait d'en faire des
êtres qui ne seront qu'un changement
c'est à dire des êtres vivants parce que
ce qui est vivant c'est ce qui change
c'est ce qui se métamorphose et et on a
tourné ce film avec les envies qu'on
sorte de la salle avec le désir d'entrer
dans cette dimension de la vie non
manning